this couple extremists their 50-year
anniversary surprising they never met me
we don't know who we are we're covering
their bill see their reaction
my boo okay loud answer
pretty wild stuff us you must be
celebrity when you travel as much as you
do well listen it's not every day you
get married 50 years I figured I'd get
your bill tonight so congratulations to
you guys yeah big deal we should
celebrate your fifth year it's the least
we could do it's the most we need more
stories like yours absolutely go enjoy
your sari - thank you most afternoon
happy anniversary fifth years a long
time they deserve more than just a
gentle being covered by surprise